Yeah, what's up. Oh,
that's easy Iranian. Oh,
right. Uh, Israeli. Oh,
Oh right. Okay. I got it now. Sardinia.
Hello, everyone. Welcome to the Lang focus channel.
And my name is Paul today's topic is the Italian language.
Italian may not get as much attention as French,
Spanish and Portuguese because it's mainly spoken in Europe rather than informer
colonies,
but it's still one of the most widely spoken languages in the European union
with around 68 million speakers there around 60 million of those speakers are in
Italy. Of course, where Italian is the official language.
Italian is also the official language of some Medina, a tiny enclave,
surrounded by Italy.
And it's also a defecto official language of the Vatican city.
It's also one of the four official languages of Switzerland where it's mainly
used in Ticino and the Southern Canton of called London.
And it's official at the regional level in Slovenian Eastern area.
And in Eastery accounty in Croatia,
it's also spoken by overseas communities among them in the United States where
over 700,000 people speak it.
According to the us census Bureau and Italian has had a cultural impact on the
rest of the world because Italian composers developed our current system of
musical notation.
Italian is the common language of musical notation at nomenclature words like
acapella, crescendo, soprano, and tempo all come from Italian.
And if you're a coffee lover,
you probably know some Italian words because Italian coffee culture has inspired
imitation throughout the world. Words like espresso from
express. So meaning pressed out coffee Grundy, which means large venti,
which means 20 as in more than 20 ounces of coffee and Trenta,
which means heart attack. Actually it means 30, but yeah,
Italian is a member of the Italo Dalmatian branch of the romance language
family. But when we talk about the Italian language,
what exactly are we talking about?
As I spoke about at length in my video on the languages of Italy,
Italy has historically had an extremely diverse variety of romance dialects,
which can be grouped together and arguably classified as dialects of various
regional languages.
The majority of these dialects belong to the Italo Dalmatian branch,
but many in Northern Italy do not.
When we speak about the Italian language in its strictest sense,
we are speaking about standard Italian,
which developed from a specific set of Italo Dalmatian, dialects, those scandal,
the Tuscan dialects that are spoken in the Tuscany region. And in particular,
the Florentine dialect of Florence, the romance dialects in Italy,
like all romance languages developed from varieties of vulgar, Latin, Latin,
originally the language of Rome and the Roman empire remained the formal
language of writing and literature up until the late middle ages and what is now
Italy. But during that period of vernacular, literary tradition began to emerge.
In other words,
literature written in the language of everyday speech rather than Latin became
more widespread.
The seeds of standard Italian were planted by Tuscan poetry and literature in
the 13th century, in the 14th century, Tuscan poet,
[inaudible] published his masterpiece,
the divine comedy in Italian originally called just Commedia,
but later referred to as Devina Commedia,
Dante was from Florence and his writing largely resembled the Tuscan dialect of
that city with some elements of Latin, as well as other dialects,
Dante is often referred to as the father of the Italian language because his
work came to be read by educated people in every region of the peninsula.
As a result,
the form of language used in his writing became the most widely understood.
And over the next couple of centuries,
it became established as the de facto standard literary language.
Other 14th century poets who greatly contributed to this were Francesco
Petrarca and Giovanni Boccaccio in the 16th century,
Pietro bamboo helped to standardize literary Italian based on the model of
[inaudible] Boccaccio and Allie, Gary later in the 19th century,
a novelist named Alessandra Manzoni had a big impact on the development of
modern standard Italian, thanks to his novel, the petroleum,
which is called [inaudible] in Italian.
This was the first novel written in Italian and is said to be the most famous
novel in the Italian language.
Even though it's not widely read in other languages,
Manzoni wrote the novel in the modern Florentine dialect with some influence
from the Florentine literature of the 14th century.
When the historical States of Italy became unified in the 19th century,
Italian became the official language of Italy and the Italian government
accepted [inaudible] proposal to make this variety standard Italian at the
time of unification, most Italians were not able to speak Italian,
meaning literary Tuscan different. Yeah.
Estimates from that time range from 2.5% of the population to 10% of the
population, even though it was the most widely understood written language,
most of the population were illiterate and lacked exposure to it.
Unifying the linguistically diverse nation became one of Italians main
functions. Nowadays, virtually all Italians are fluent in Italian,
which exists alongside its Elise vast array of romance dialects though,
in some areas, Italian has largely replaced local dialects.
What's the Italian like first let's look at a few basic words and phrases.
Hello, ciao.
Notice letter C here represents the soft Chuck sound.
That's how it's pronounced before I or eat before a O or you,
it represents a heart cut sound as in Quantico,
sta which means how much does it cost? Good morning.
Bongiorno notice here that the letter G represents a soft G sound again,
that's the pronunciation before I,
or eat before a O U or a consonant it's pronounced to go like
in the word for thank you, guests. Yeah.
Aside from the hard G notice the pronunciation of the letter Z in Italian,
it represents a sound or Z at the beginning of words,
though, there are exceptions goodbye.
Video or chow.
Note, the pronunciation of the Italian R sound. It's a rolled R sound.
In other words,
a trill it's a longer trill sound when doubled and it's a tap when it appears
between vowels. You'll notice it in the next couple of words as well.
Please. Beautiful order. I'd like vote today. I'd like the fish, please.
[inaudible] there for voting.
Notice the pronunciation of se in base.
It's pronounced like before I N E but before other bowels or before
continents, it's pronounced Schutte like in the phrase, meaning, excuse me,
miss cruisy. On top of the sound,
notice that S is pronounced Z between vowels it's voiced
where's the station.
[Inaudible] recalled that.
The letter Z sounds like not Z. I love Italy.
Um, well Italia, I understand tepee SCO.
I don't understand non-coffee score.
Now let's jump into some more sentences and see what we can learn about the
language.
[Inaudible] English. Is it.
This means Mark speaks English and Italian word for word it.
Marco speaks Italian and English in simple sentences like this,
the word order is the same as an English. Another thing you might notice,
and you may have noticed in the previous set of basic words and phrases is the
strong tendency for Italian words to end in a vowel.
That's true for almost all words in Italian. They end in vowels.
We saw two exceptions in the previous set of basic words,
eel meaning and known meaning no, or not.
Both of them short function words. There are five vowel letters in Italian.
Ah, eh, a E Aw, Oh,
Ooh. Two of them, E N O have two sounds open and closed.
It's worth noting that different regional accents don't always distinguish
between the open and closed vowel sounds. So if you can't,
it's not the end of the world. I guess there are also diphthongs though.
They are usually just a simple combination of two vowels.
Another thing to notice is that each of the words with more than one syllable is
stressed on the penultimate syllable. In other words, the second to last.
Mariko Barla Italiano English.
This isn't true for all words in Italian, but it's generally the case.
The verb bottler is the third person singular conjugation of the verb
in the present tense. Italian has three classes of verbs,
audit verbs at verbs and EDA verbs.
Notice that the three classes are conjugated slightly differently with some
slightly different verb. Endings, Otto verbs are almost all regular,
but among Edda and EDA verbs.
There's a significant number of irregular verbs that veer from the regular
patterns. Let's look at another sentence.
[Inaudible] of brands or G lasagna.
It means I ate my favorite food for lunch today. Lasagna word for word it's.
I have eaten my food.
Favorite for lunch today, lasagna,
I guess I didn't really need to translate lasagna in the sentence.
The syntax is a little different from English. Unlike the previous sentence,
first of all,
the subject pronoun can be dropped because the person a number are clear from
the conjugation of the verb. Oh,
is the first person singular present tense form of the verb of the,
which means to have here it's functioning as the auxiliary verb for [inaudible].
This is the tense.
[Inaudible] equivalent.
To the present, perfect tense in English,
but in Italian it's also generally used where we would use the simple past in
English. This is one of 14 tenses in Italian, though. There are 21.
If we include the imperative present and past infinitives present and past
participles and present and past Jurrens,
some of those tenses are simple tenses and others are compound tenses formed
from an auxiliary verb.
Plus the past participle of the main verb or the [inaudible] for
most verbs,
compound tenses are formed with the auxiliary verb of the though there is a
subset of verbs that take S it meaning to be instead.
These are usually intransitive verbs that describe movement or a state or
condition. Let's look at the phrase, eat a meal.
Chibo meal is a possessive adjective like my in
English, the possessive adjectives, as well as other adjectives,
like put a Frito agree with the gender.
And number of the known nouns ending in Oh, are usually masculine,
like Chibo and nouns ending an a are usually feminine,
like total meaning cake,
some nouns end in E and these can be either masculine or feminine.
For instance, Bonnie meaning bread is masculine while cat admit,
meaning meat is feminine in Italian,
possessive adjectives are proceeded by a definite article like.
You know, me or Chiba lamina at, or that he may be Scott,
the linear recheck it.
Notice that there are different definite articles that agree with gender and
number masculine and feminine, singular, and masculine and feminine plural.
There are actually a couple more that appear in certain phonetic contexts, law,
masculine,
singular before S plus another continent or before Z look L
apostrophe, both masculine and feminine singular before vowels and
masculine plural before vowels,
before S another continent or the continent Z or before GN.
So there's.
You Chiba [inaudible] land and us lat Orta Eby. Scott,
the lady check that [inaudible] notice that the adjective,
but if he thought.
After the gnome, whereas an English,
it comes before it in Italian functional adjectives,
like possessive adjectives and numbers come before the noun.
Descriptive adjectives normally come after the now,
but they sometimes come before it.
The general rule is that adjectives that are strictly factual come after the,
now these are called denotative adjectives. For example,
[inaudible] the fresh cake fresh is denotative.
It's factual adjectives that are quantitative. In other words,
they imply something about the noun come before. For example,
[inaudible] the delicious cake. Some adjectives can come before or after,
but with a difference in meaning, for example,
Rommel Paul veto means the poor man he's factually poor while.
Bothered a warmer means the.
Miserable man. A couple of notes about pronunciation and orthography.
Oh,
note that the letter H is silent in Italian in the phrase [inaudible] can we
see two different consonant sounds that are written with the G plus another
consonant letter GL represents the sound. Yeah,
this is one of the trickier sounds for learners of Italian.
It's kind of like the double L sound in the word million,
but not quite GN represents the sound. Yeah.
A palatal nasal, something like Nia,
but not quite also note the CHN, no key.
And also in zoo kiddo,
C H is always pronounced as a hard sound in Italian. Similarly,
G H is always pronounced as a hard gut sound.
Buggy D form another sentence lays stainless
[inaudible].
This means you're wearing a nice shirt word for word it's you stay wearing a
nice shirt. This sentence could also mean she is wearing a nice shirt.
This is a polite sentence. And in polite speech,
third person pronouns and conjugations are used for the second person.
Lei is the third person feminine, singular subject pronoun,
and lay with a capital L is the polite second person singular,
but lay would be capitalized here anyway,
since it's at the beginning of the sentence. So out of context,
the sentence is ambiguous, but not in context stain,
the sand is a present continuous construction.
It uses the verb study as the auxiliary verb and the Geron of the main verb
here or the verb is [inaudible] because this is a polite sentence study
is in it's third person,
singular conjugation stop rather than second person singular
notice. Also the indefinite article here,
indefinite articles agree with the gender of the noun. Oh,
is the feminine indefinite article. And it agrees with the feminine Marietta.
There'll be four vowels.
The feminine article is with an apostrophe [inaudible].
The masculine definite article is as in
[inaudible] UNO before Z or S with another continent UNO studio.
There are no plural indefinite articles, but part of the, of articles,
meaning some or any are used instead partners of articles,
combined deep meaning of with a definite article.
As we saw before this adjective here also agrees with the noun in gender,
as well as in number is the feminine singular form.
It comes before the noun because it's connotative, it's not factual,
but implies something subjective about the shirt.
Italian is a beautiful language and one that captures the imagination of people
all over the world because of the huge Italian cultural influence,
both historical and contemporary, I guess that's why Italian is the fourth.
Most widely studied language in the world. Some sources say fifth,
but let's go with fourth.
The question of the day for native speakers of Italian,
what other features of Italian do you want others to know about?
And for learners of Italian,
what have you found the most fun or interesting about the language?
If you enjoyed this video,
then check out Lang focus on the various social media platforms like Facebook,
Instagram, Twitter, and of course, YouTube. And as always,
I want to give a very special thanks to my patrons on Patrion,
especially my top tier, your patrons, whose names are right here on the screen,
many extra special, thanks to them and to everyone.
Thank you for watching and have a nice day.